[Music]  Kim and Kourtney Kardashian flaunt their  bikini buds while on vacation in Turks  and Caicos the famous sisters enjoyed a  short trip to the Caribbean  along with courts 24-year old beau Yunus  Benjamin over the weekend and it looked  like total vacay goals in true  Kardashian fashion the Keeping Up stars  documented the jaunt on social media  sharing their gorgeous beach views fun  while bike riding around the island and  some sexy shots of course Kim posted a  video showing off her curves and a teeny  red two-piece while her 38 year old  sister shared a pic of her toned bod in  a grey bikini after taking a dip in the  gorgeous blue water even yonas got in on  the action with this shirtless snap  rockin camo shorts and washboard abs  [Music]  [Applause]